okay uh good morning today we are doing
Jesus the most famous man who has ever
lived there are about two billion people
on this planet about a quarter of the
human race who worship
him so who is he what does he believe
and why is he so important okay so let's
look at first what we know about the
historical Jesus there was a man who
lived
lived um and the these are facts that
Scholars most Scholars agree about
him he was born in the year 4
BC um in a place called
Galilee and this is important because
Galilee it is in Judea um Israel
today and Galilee is a meeting place of
many different cultures
religions and
beliefs uh this is part of the Roman
Empire and this is really a center of
much of the world at that time
okay then
he um was a student of someone called
John the
Baptist John the Baptist is a major
Jewish religious leader who believed in
baptism
as a way of cleansing you of your sins
so that you prep so that you may prepare
for the Kingdom of Heaven God is coming
but you must first cleanse your sins and
restart yourself in order to be worthy
of his
arrival okay but then um after some time
with John the Baptist Jesus start to
create his own following and Jesus was
preaching his own message that um was
very
attractive and he developed a very large
following he was pretty well known for
his healing powers so if you were sick
he could heal you uh through the power
of faith and
belief then what we also know is about
the year 30 to 33 um CE so was like when
he was like 34 or 37 he was crucified by
the Romans
okay
crucification we don't know why they
crucified
him but we believe he was
crucified and crucify
crucification was the worst way to
die um and crucification was basically
reserved only for two types of
people
either uh Bandits Pirates
or uh Rebels people who defied the Roman
State and it was really reserved for
poor illiterate individuals who had no
status because
crucification um you may not know this
but when they crucify you okay they na
um they nail you to a cross and they put
you up okay you don't die because of
bleeding or because of pain you die
because of Suffocation you suffocate to
death um so what happens you're you're
on the cross and eventually you start to
lose power and you start to you can't
even hold up your neck okay so you're
suffocating to death because you can't
breathe it takes about three days to die
so it's really the worst way to die okay
and that's what happened to
Jesus and historically this is all that
we know about
him okay this is what's been confirmed
by Scholars by archaeologists by
researchers Jesus is the most studied
individual in human history no one comes
close but we we we really don't know
much about him
okay all right so now that we looked at
the Historical Jesus let's look at the
biblical Jesus because these are two
very different individuals so Jesus in
the Bible is the Son of God okay the Son
of
God and he's in heaven enjoying his life
but he sees the world Underneath Him and
he pies us and he wants
to liberate us from our pain and our
suffering he wants to redeem us and to
atone for our sins and our crimes and
he's born of a virgin mother named
Mary and from a very early age he is a
religious genius who
attracts followers to him and he
developed and he has 12
Apostles uh 12 Apostles
and he's determined to
preach the coming of the Kingdom of
Heaven okay God is coming and we must be
ready for him he also preaches a
religion of
forgiveness and Redemption and
compassion and generosity and
mercy
so he will say things like do not judge
others let those who are without fault
without
sin without mistakes be the first to
cast the stone okay so we shouldn't
judge others because we all have our own
faults we should be generous and open
and compassionate to others okay so he
was pring that message he was also in
many ways a social revolutionary because
he was upset with the religion of the
times at that time uh the Jewish
religion was controlled very much by the
priesthood so you show your faith by
making animal sacrifices by basically
paying a tribute to God and Jesus
thought that was wrong you show your
faith by being a good person by being
generous by refusing materialism and
greed and corruption you don't do you
don't show your faith through animal
sacrifice okay and as such he angered
the
religious uh Powers at that time
especially the priests of the temple in
Jerusalem So eventually he was betrayed
by his Apostle named Judas es scariot
okay Judas escar
reported uh the crimes of Jesus to the
religious
and in turn the religious Powers the
priests of the temple turn them over to
the Roman governor of that time okay his
name is ponus
pilot ponus pilot and ponus pilate
really didn't want to be involved he
didn't know what crime Jesus committed
but the priests insisted the Jewish
people insisted and so as a sacrifice
Pontius Pilate agreed to crucify Jesus
right so Jesus was
crucified and after he was crucified and
he died he was resurrected how do we
know because he appeared before his
Apostles and told him look I've CA I've
come to this earth in order to redeem
and atone for the sins of men I have now
I have now done so therefore God will
come and cleanse the Earth of all sin
spread my message spread my gospel
gospel is Greek for good
news and I will return to you okay so he
there's a promise that there will be a
second coming and when and when Jesus
returns he will come as
prophesies um on top of clouds and he
will spite all of God's enemies and they
will build a
paradise Okay so that's what the Bible
says and by the way um what's really
important for us to understand is there
are contradictions in the Bible because
all that we know about about Jesus comes
from four
biographies in the Bible okay the
gospels it's good news and they're
written by four different individuals
who we name
Mark uh Matthew Luke and John and again
there are inconsistencies within their
biographies okay but if if you put them
put them together this is a story of um
Jesus now when you hear the story
there's certain problems with the story
the biggest story is sorry the biggest
problem is if he is in fact the Son of
God if he is
divine how do we explain the
crucification and the
resurrection why does the Son of God
have to die
and how does a Son of God die okay and
this is one of the most perplexing and
confusing qu questions in Christianity
and it's been with us for about 2,000
years okay so no one's really resolved
this issue but the standard explanation
is
this why did Jesus have to come to Earth
the reason why is God and the children
he created us are at War there's a
religious war going on
God created us and put us in the Garden
of Eden Adam and Eve and God told us
listen this is Paradise you can do
whatever you want but there's only one
rule you must not break do not eat from
the Tree of knowledge of Good and Evil
that's all we have to do don't eat that
fruit but we disobeyed him and God in
his anger
exiled us from
Paradise and in our stupidity in our
ignorance in our in our
selfishness we never came to recognize
our own original sin our own failings
and so we continue to make more and more
mistakes which has led to a uh more a
corrupt and decent World God Up in
Heaven is Waiting for us to to ask for
forgiveness to admit our
mistakes and we refuse to do so because
we're kids we're
stupid but God even though he's merciful
even though he is wise must be asked for
forgiveness before he can forgive us
okay and Jesus who is the Son of God he
recognizes this conflict he recognizes
this in pass and he decides he will come
to Earth and he will sacrifice himself
in order to atone for the sins of
man and release us from our own
stupidity and our
ignorance and allow God to forgive
us but you think about it this is all
the work of God
because God is allowing us to forgive
ourselves
okay and in many
ways what this is doing is solving the
problem of Achilles remember we talked
about The Iliad right and in The Iliad
there's a central conflict in the in the
ilad and it's a problem of Achilles
remember that AES is this great warrior
who refuses to fight for the Greeks
because Egon the King has insulted him
but he really wants to fight eventually
in his uh arrogance he causes the death
of his friend
Petras and when Petrus dies it makes
Achilles even more
Angry um at himself okay and that's why
he takes out his anger on Hector he he
doesn't recognize his own failings he
doesn't recognize his own
sin and it took pram to release him from
his anger remember pram forgave
Achilles and when Prime forgave Achilles
it released Achilles from his own
guilt okay the problem though
is if Prime never forgave Achilles then
Achilles would have been stuck in his
depression and his
anger okay so this is Achilles
problem if we can't forgive ourselves
who will forgive us and the answer of
course is Jesus will forgive you okay
and this is the fundamental idea of
Christianity do not be angry at yourself
do not hate yourself do not feel guilty
because Jesus has forgiven you which
allows you to be a new you you can now
be whoever you want because Jesus has
atoned you or taken away your sins and
your guilt okay if you believe in him
then you will become a new person you
can be become whoever you want to be all
right so this is the idea of um
Christianity Jesus
made his made the sacrifice in order to
release us from our own guilt and our
own shame so we can be free to worship
God In His glory
okay any
questions not only that but because of
the sacrifice of
Jesus everyone is now free to worship
God because before
remember God was a religion within
Judaism only Jews had access to God and
even within the religion itself really
only the high priest had access to God
so Jesus came to Earth to tell us all
humans the entire human race God is
within all of us you don't have to be a
Jewish person to believe in God you can
just be a person who wants to believe in
God okay and this is an idea that is
beauti
y um encapsulated in the gospel of Mark
okay so let's read the section together
and this is when Jesus has been
crucified and he has died okay then
Jesus gave a loud cry and breathed his
last so the Son of God has died okay
he's completed his
mission and the curtain of the temple
was torn into two from top to bottom
right this is a extremely important
sentence the curtain is the door inside
the temple and the curtain is what
protects the inner sanctum the holiest
room it's called the holy of the holies
okay from everyone else only the high
priest can enter there why because that
room is where God
is okay so when the curtain is torn into
two what this is telling us is God is
now released into the world God was
trapped inside the temple but now that
the C has been torn into two because of
the sacrif sacrifice of Jesus God can
now enter the world and we can all have
access to him he's no longer trapped
inside this curtain okay does that make
sense and when the Centurion the
Centurion is the Roman not not the
Jewish person who stood facing him okay
so the Centurian was watching guard to
make sure no one came to save save Jesus
saw that in this way he breed his last
he said truly this man was God's son so
the first person to recognize who Jesus
really is are not his
Apostles but a
Roman who saw him die so he the
Centurion is history's first Christian
because he sees himself this man this
Jesus was truly the Son of God a Divine
figure who came to Earth in order to
liberate us from our sins and to build a
connection between us and God
okay so this is the very basis of the
Christian faith you believe that Jesus
came to Earth in order to atone for our
sins and to liberate us from
the corruption of religion in the world
around
us does this make sense guys any
questions so far before I
continue okay so while this is a
beautiful story and it's touched people
for thousands of years and millions of
people it really doesn't make much sense
okay there are problems within the
story the biggest problem is the idea of
atonement and original sin remember
before we studed the Bible we studied
this we studyed the story of Adam and
Eve and we said very clearly what the
Bible says is both God
Yahweh and Adam and Eve were at fault
okay Adam and Eve did disob disobey God
and did eat from from the tree but God
lied to them and God we also said
recognize his
mistake also
remember God already punished us for our
Disobedience God said to Adam from now
on you have to work hard to grow food
for your family and he said to Eve from
now on you will suffer pain in your
labor when you gave birth you will
suffer IMM men's pain okay so God has
already punished us for our original sin
right then the last problem is God
kicked us out of
paradise because he feared that we would
eat from the Tree of Life which would
give us eternal life right so this idea
of original sin and I told me doesn't
make any
sense also why is God angry at us if
he's God he's
Perfection why does he have to be angry
at us what do we do to piss him off
would a father be angry at his children
always is it the responsibility of the
children to ask for forgiveness or the
responsibil of the father to
forgive his
children okay so this is an
extremely problematic story it sounds
beautiful when you start think about it
it becomes extremely
problematic
also there are things in the story that
are not historically accurate all right
so the biggest problem is this the Bible
says very explicitly at times that it
was the Jews who killed Jesus and this
is problematic because this has been
used to justify anti-semetic behavior
and language throughout centuries okay
but historically this is not what
happened all right so let me give you a
few reasons why I do not believe this is
what happened the first reason
is um what the Bible does not recognize
is at this time in Jerusalem there are
many different religious
authorities among the Jewish people and
they are in conflict with each other the
three major factions are called the um
seduces the
sad uh the Sadducees the
Pharisees and
theen okay these are three major
factions the seduces are the aristocrats
they're the priests who are in charge of
the temple they they're basically the
central authority of the religion but
then you have the
Pharisees who argue that what matters is
not animal sacrifice but obedience to
the law of
God okay and these are reformers and
eventually from them we emerge what we
call the rabbis basically the current
leaders of the Jewish faith and then you
have the C who
believe that there is um an apop coming
God is returning to Earth and what's
important is to deny the matur reality
to live frugally to live in peace to
live in harmony together okay and guess
what guys these three groups hate each
other they were always at conflict with
each
other but they never went to war with
each other because they believe that
they were all God's people therefore we
should argue we should kill each other
okay so the idea that
these priests
would send Jesus to his death doesn't
really fit into the culture and the
practice of people at that time okay
that's the first
problem second problem
is the Bible makes ponus pilot look to
be a re it the
Bible makes ponus pilot look to be very
reluctant and even at times sympathetic
towards Jesus it's a very pro- Roman
attitude but we have a lot of
information about P pilot the governor
of Judea at this time okay what we know
about him is he was a violent Thug like
most Roman Romans okay the Romans have a
notorious attitude of being violent
first okay they're not very political
they're not very um strategic they like
to kill people okay and at time Pontius
Pilate had a major conflict with the
Jews of Jerusalem the Jews the first law
of the Ten Commandments is you shall not
worship false
Idols but ponti pilot represent the
Roman Empire and their false idol was
their Emperor so the emperor um was the
face of the emperor tiberious was in
coins and there were flags and posters
around him okay and P pilot wanted to
bring the Cult of Caesar to Jerusalem
which offended the Jews because the Jews
are not allowed to have false Idols
inside their City their holy city and
this created a lot of conflicts between
P pilot and the Jews there were some
circumstances where the Jews went to pus
pilot to complain and pus pilot says if
you don't get out of my house I'm going
to kill all of you and the Jews start to
line up and says come here's my neck
come come kill me okay and so P pilot
had to relent he had no face the Jews
were all willing to die to prot protect
their religion so ponus pilot was not a
very political not a very Savvy
individual okay he kep he continued to
offend the Jews so the idea that ponus
pilate would be sympathetic towards
Jesus uh makes no sense if P pilot could
kill a Jew he would kill a Jew okay
any questions so
far okay so I'm gonna make an argument
okay I'm going to explain to you that
the Bible what it says isn't really
accurate right I'm going to reconstruct
the historical Jesus and I'm going to
tell you based on my reading of the
history and of the Bible what he really
believed okay and um just to be clear
I'm not a
scholar I really haven't studed the
Bible that much okay all all I've done
is a lot of independent research so take
my words we're going to Salt okay and
feel free to challenge me or
question uh my argument at any time just
raise your hand all right so um
before I talk about Jesus I want to talk
about the historical circumstance of
Jerusalem and Judea at this time okay so
let's do a brief summary of what we
learned so far we've learned that um
King David was the founder of the
religion okay one of the main founders
of the religion and at this time in
history in about a thousand BCE this is
really the height and peak of the state
of Israel and they're very confident
very open very
generous okay but after David dies his
son Solomon is not able to keep the
kingdom together okay and it splits into
two uh the northern
kingdom and um
Judah over time because Israel is in
such a strategic location right the
Levant is the center of the world both
of these places will be conquered by by
foreigners the northern kingdom will
become conquered by the
Assyrians Judah will be conquered by the
Babylonians and the elite are sent off
into Exile in Babylon where they
basically
develop uh the religion of
Judaism uh of its modern form okay the
Persians
return the
um Jews back to uh Judea um Israel and
there they write the Bible okay and this
is comes about
and but then the pers are conquered by
the Greeks by alander great in
301 and now
tmy the Greek General is in charge of
the area and Tommy is in charge of Egypt
and Egypt is very wealthy so tommi
prefers to use money to resolve disputes
so what he does is basically say to the
Jewish Elite the priest hey your
religion is really interesting when of
you guys come to Alexandria the capital
of Egypt and translate your Hebrew Bible
into the Greek bible so that we can all
appreciate the beauty and power of your
words okay and we call this Bible the
seetu
seetu and it's it's a very important you
don't have to know this word but like
remember this is the Greek Bible it
becomes the basis of Christianity okay
because most people by the time
Christianity comes won't read Hebrew
they'll be able to read
Greek but then in uh 167
BC julus is conquered by the saluan
Empire antus and antus is a thug so he
comes and he desecrates a temple by
offering a sacrifice to Zeus a pig
sacrifice to Zeus in their Temple and
this offends the Jews so much they want
they launch a decades long gorilla
Warfare against the saluan empire okay
in
BCE the Romans
conquer um Jerusalem Pompei the great
the Roman general comes and conquers lay
Siege to Jerusalem he kills tens of
thousands of Jews and enslaves others
and send us across the Empire okay
so at this point in history and and
Jesus is born um a few decades later at
4 BC
right the Jews have become extremely
fanatical about the
religion okay they need to they need to
explain if they are the chosen people if
God their Yahweh is the best God in the
world why is this crap happening right
why did their uh Kingdom become
dissolved and then conquered by
foreigners and not only that but these
foreign powers the Babylonians the um
Greeks the Romans they come and they
insult their God they burn down the
temple they desecrate the temple and
they kill a lot of God's chosen people
so why is this happening and the
explanation there's a twofold
explanation the first explanation
is we were not loyal enough to God God
sent these foreigners to conquer us
because we disobey God we worship
foreign idols and we refuse to follow
God's
Commandments okay that's the first
explanation the second explanation is
the idea of um
apocalyptic
eschatology okay apoc sorry apocalyptic
eschatology okay this is a very big term
and I need you guys to know it because
it's important for future classes okay
so so let's look at what this means
eschatology is Greek comes from the
Greek escaton which means the end
okay the end end of the world end times
apoc apocalypse is Greek for Revelation
or unveiling okay revealing so
apocalyptic eschatology means telling
you how the world ends with the return
of
God okay so all this crap is happening
is God is Planning to make his return to
Smite all his enemies to destroy all
these Empires who have the fire
his
name all right and this is what most
Jews believed at this time of Jesus when
Jesus was born it was assumed that God
was about to return to the world and
destroy all his enemies and there were a
lot of prophets running around preaching
this message Jesus Jesus was one of them
but he was not unique in his message
that the kingdom of heaven was returning
okay so any questions about this
history are you guys
clear okay let's continue all right so
this is the
history um but at the same time what's
happening is because the lvon is really
the center of the world it's a meeting
place of the world every single major
religion is in the lavant and Jesus is
absorbing and trying to understand these
different religions okay so let's talk
about the major religions you have uh
the Greeks with Plato okay so let's
remind ourselves of what platonic
philosophy is Plato believes God is
called the form of the good from the
good and from the form the good will
emate at other ideas like
reason truth beauty Justice and then
these will emanate physical
manifestations called the forms okay so
this is called the realm of forms this
is basically Heaven okay you can see
this as
heaven we live in a shadow
reality which um is just an
imitation of the form of the good and
our objective in life is to St
philosophy in order to return to the
form of the good okay only
mathematics will help us return to the
form of the good PL got this idea from
the Egyptians okay and the Egyptians
called this idea sacred
geometry
mathematics because sacred geometry is a
language and thought of the Gods okay
does that make sense that's why it's
Plato also at this time because of the
influence of the Persians you have zor
aism okay zor
aism remember in Zionism the Creator is
is a hor Master he is the perfect God of
Light and he creates a perfect world
where we humans are free to choose
whatever we want this world eventually
be became corrupted by an evil God who
is equal to Azor Masta okay and now we
humans must fight for good we can choose
to fight for evil but we fight for good
that will allow good to win out in the
end eventually will emerge a savior a
messiah a hero who will lead the army of
light into a final battle against the
Army of Darkness and in this battle the
army of light will
Triumph and then will emerge a river and
then everyone who's ever died will be
resurrected from the dead and everyone
will be forced to cross this River if
you have been a good person if you have
f for the truth if you've been
compassionate you will cross this
River and you will feel cleansed of all
your sins and your mistakes and you will
emerge as a perfect Soul who will live
in Paradise forever but if you've been a
bad
person okay you will burn In this River
and then you'll be condemned to
suffering for
eternity okay this is zorin ISM then you
have
Buddhism and Hinduism okay and again
guys um remember this world is
interconnected so the Greeks know
Buddhism very well and and the Buddhist
know uh the Greeks very well okay so and
Jesus will have access to Buddhist and
Hindu teachings in in the Buddhist and
Hindu
tradition there's a true reality called
Brahman okay so it's F think of this as
a form of the good we live in a false
reality where we have to suffer in pain
but through our good works through
Dharma we can achieve Moka what is MSHA
Moka means Liberation back into the
Brahman okay so uh Hinduism is very
similar to uh
platonism all right at the same time
besides religions there are also major
philosophies that are roaming around
this area okay so you have sism which is
which is what the Romans believe you
have uh
cism and you have epicurism okay so
these are some of the major ones cism is
what Jesus believed which is a rejection
of all material reality okay cynics
believe that it's important to wear bad
clothes and to beg for food because
material reality is a lie or it's
evil okay at the same time you also have
these um what we call Pagan religions or
Pagan rituals usually around the cult of
dianis okay um we will talk about this
later on in our in our class because
this is very important but all I want
you to remember is These Are pagan
rituals where people come together and
they use psychedelics they use drugs to
get really high in order to increase
their religious
ecstasy and this is to create um a a
feeling of Oneness
interconnectedness what's really
important of the Pagan rituals is to
focus on
egalitarianism okay so you could be a
Slave you be a rich person but once you
enter these rituals you're all one the
same and they reject the social
hierarchy of the real world okay not all
but many of these Pagan rituals do that
so as you can see at this time there's
just tremendous religious fever in the
world everyone's seeking truth
everyone's seeking a more peaceful more
interconnected a more real
world okay and Jesus is operating within
this major climate and Jesus is a major
religious sorry Jesus is a unique
religious genius who is able to synphase
all these ideas into a new
religion okay but it's not called
Christianity right it's not called
Christianity Jesus is not the one who is
a found of Christianity that person is
named Paul we'll do Paul next class but
Jesus founds a new religion that
attracts major
followers okay and so what is this new
religion called okay so um at that time
obviously there was not there was not a
name for this new religion but today we
call these new religions narcissism
okay Jesus was the founder of a religion
called narcissism not Christianity
narcissism there's a difference all
right so what is narcissism all right if
you look at most religions there are
three major
leers there's a secret
leer okay which is only available to the
founder as well as his closest followers
there is a inner leer okay an inner leer
which is what he teaches his disciples
and there is a public lay an alter
ler okay
which is what he preaches to the public
okay do you understand so most religions
will have this three tower system a
secret ler which is the secret teachings
an inner lar which is what the disciples
are taught and then there's a public lar
okay
so and what's important first to
understand is these three lers operate
at different levels and they speak
different truths but they're all
interconnected okay they're coherent
and they're one and the same all right
so Jesus was a gnostic what does this
mean let's look at the alter L okay what
Jesus was preaching was a religion of
compassion of forgiveness of mercy of
egalitarianism so let's look at Matthew
the Gospel of Matthew this is from the
uh Sermon on the Mount okay and this is
what he says blessed are the poor in
spirit for theirs is the kingdom of
heaven
the people in this world who have value
are not the rich but the
poor because God favors
them if you're a poor person you will
find fallace you will find Solace and
comfort in this idea you may
be poor you may not be able to eat
enough but God loves you the most okay
so this is what Jesus teaches the public
but then the question then is why would
this be true all right why would this be
true and so for this make sense we need
to understand the inner and the secret
Lear which is not revealed to us in
Matthew but there's a secret Gospel
called The Gospel of Thomas which we
recently discovered okay uh this was
discovered in 1945 in a in a a town
called
n and this gospel is not in the Bible
but it reveals to
us what Jesus thinks okay so let's look
at what he says there are two things
okay there is light within a man of
light and he lights up the whole world
if he does not shine he is Darkness
okay what does this mean it can mean
many things so and as I explained to you
you can look at this quotation from
three different layers at the public
layer there's light within a man of
light and he lights up the whole world
if he does not shine he is darkness in
the public lar it means we have to be
good people okay God favors people who
do good things who are generous who are
compassionate okay that's a public Lear
then there's an inner lay okay the inner
lay is what he's saying to his disciples
is if you want to follow me you must
give up the world if you're wealthy give
up your wealth if you have if you're
poor give up your children and your wife
and follow me be an example to everyone
else okay but there's also a secret
layer a secret layer and and to and
let's look at the secret lay the secret
lay is a secret knowledge about the
world a secret understanding of how the
world works that only Jesus and his
closest followers understand and
recognize okay and this is what we call
narcissism the idea is this and it
follows it basically follows along along
the lines of Plato and Buddhism Hinduism
okay all
right in the beginning there's a God A
perect God Called the
monad or the one and he's perfect he is
eternal he is
immutable uh and he's perfect okay the
the god of
Plato the monad creates diads okay peers
that are perfect one of them is called
Sophia and then these peers create with
the permission of the Mad um Triads okay
and this is all a perfect world because
Perfection creates perfection the
problem is one of these Gods Nam Sophia
which is knowledge she decides she can
be like a mo monat remember what makes
monat special is he creates new things
out of his own
thoughts the diads are forced to couple
with each other in order to create new
things so sopia wants to create her own
thing herself without permission of her
partner without permission of the monad
okay but when she did that she's defying
the rules of the universe and therefore
she creates a
monster okay this is a monster and
Sophia is ashamed by what she's done
okay she's like oh my God this was a
mistake this was a travesty so what she
does is she hides this monster in a
different reality okay she clouds up
this reality and this monster is
ignorant of the true reality so the
monster doesn't
know um that he's a monster and he and
he thinks he's a God and he's lonely so
he starts to create the world us okay
the in the Bible the monster's name is
Yahweh and he Crees Adam and Eve and he
creates the
world and the world is completely
screwed up because it's all being
created by a
monster
okay and so this is the origin of sin
and Corruption and evil in this world
because the our God is a
Monster who is in defiance of the true
God
okay and that's
why blessed are the poor in spirit for
theirs is the Kingdom of Heaven because
if you're poor you are
defying the material reality
to win in this game created by a monster
you yourself have have to become a
monster therefore the wealthy the
powerful are evil people if you're poor
you don't participate in this evilness
and therefore you're you are blessed by
God and it was God who who will
um redeem you and reward you at the end
of the
world okay and who is Jesus Jesus is the
son or a a do a a son of the monad who's
come to the world to reveal us this
truth about our
world
okay and this is what he says there is a
light within a man of light and he
lights up the whole world if he does not
shine he is Darkness okay we our bodies
are evil why because we feel pain we die
a perfect God would not make us alive
because it makes no sense why would a
perfect God condemn his children to the
suffering we suffer every day that makes
no sense only a monster would do this
but even though the monster creates us
there is still a Divine spark in us that
comes from the
monad and if we recognize this and we
choose a life of goodness by seeking
true knowledge then this light will let
the
world but we CH but if we do not do this
then we'll continue to suffer in
darkness okay and this is what the
secret teaching
is guys in each of us there's a Divine
spark of the monad and so we can defy or
escape this reality created by a monster
but you have to recognize this okay and
this is a secret teaching of
Jesus all right let's look at one more
quotation from the Gospel of Thomas to
truly understand this idea when you make
the two one and when you make the inside
like the outside and the outside like
the inside and the above like the below
and when you make the male and the
female one the same so that the male not
be male or female and when you fashion
eyes in the place of an eye then will
you enter the kingdom okay how can you
escape this world you can escape this
world by
seeing this world everything is
interconnected these categories Rich
poor male female are
created by the authorities in this world
who worship a
monster we must recognize the
connectedness of the humanity in each
and every one of us that's why it's
important to show Mercy to be
compassionate because we're all stuck
together and it's only by recognizing
our common Humanity that will allow us
to escape this
world
okay when you fashion your eyes in the
place of eye okay when you truly
see then you
escape you have eyes and you and you
think that what you see is true but it's
not true it's all fake it's all a lie
you have to see with your soul with the
Divine spark that is in you and then you
will see the
truth all
right in this religion
why did Jesus die well I mean he died
because it's a good thing okay if you
die you are able to escape back into the
true reality but also he died in order
to awaken us to inspire us to grab our
attention all right because his death
was so
tragic that it all us
into focus our attention into Jesus and
when we focus on Jesus
we focus on his teachings and slowly
over time for our
own self-discovery process we're able to
recognize the true teaching the secret
teaching of Jesus and once we recognize
the true teaching of Jesus we're able to
practice a compassionate generous and
merciful life we're able to bring light
onto the world and in our death we're
able to escape back into the true
reality okay and that's the the true
teaching of
Jesus
okay so does that make sense
guys all right so now that we've Rec
constructed his true
belief let's look at his
life what happened okay
so Jesus at some point he's able to
develop his theory of the world his
religion and if you're if you believe in
your theory you want to spread it out
okay you want people to know your
theory so he goes to Jerusalem which is
the religious capital of the Jews okay
if you want people to pay attention to
you and you want people to recognize
you're speaking the truth you have to go
to Jerusalem the problem is this first
of all the Romans are in Jerusalem and
they want to kill prophets because they
see Jewish prophets as problematic
second problem is when you go to
Jerusalem you're competing against other
religious
authorities okay you're now threatening
the authority of the seduces the
Pharisees and the asens but Jesus
doesn't have protectors he doesn't have
like a powerful political faction
protecting him so the Romans saw an
opportunity to teach the Jews a lesson
so they arrested him and then they
crucified him okay does that make
sense but after did so what they didn't
recognize is this would turn him into a
hero okay because at this time everyone
is thinking about apoc apocalyptic
eschatology they're thinking the world
is is ending the Messiah is coming and
they are so shocked by the death of
their Pro of Jesus that they start to
talk about him okay let's do a thought
experiment let's just say I'm a king and
everyone hates me everyone hates me I'm
a king but everyone hates me and there
are three prophets who speak like speak
up against me okay the first prophet
Prophet a
says I am a son of a
okay my Mo my mother was a
prostitute the prophet B is I killed my
brother to use up the throne okay that's
what prophet B says Prophet C
says I steal from the Army okay this the
the money not supposed to supposed to go
to the Army I steal all right so these
are three prophets who talk trash about
me and the people are confused as to who
to believe who do I follow Prophet a
prophet b or Prophet C right so how do
you know someone's speaking the truth
well you know when the
King kills someone right is that make
sense if I kill Prophet B it means
Prophet B must be speaking the truth and
therefore you will start to follow the
teachings of Propet B okay so in this
time because the Romans killed
Jesus they turn Jesus into a hero and
people are now interested in the
teachings of Jesus and that's why he
became so
famous okay and also if you think think
about it narcissism is really appealing
to people it makes a lot of sense
okay but then
comes the most important question in
Christianity which is this if Jesus
himself was a gnostic if this is what he
taught that there is a light in us and
we must constantly work hard to let let
the world to shine the world with our
lightness how do we go from here
narcissism
to uh the Bible modern day
Christianity which teaches teaches us
that Jesus came to the world to redeem
us from our
sins and that he will return to save the
world how did we get from here to hear
and these are like two radically
different
conceptions
of the world in fact if Jesus were alive
today and he saw that we worshiped him
as a
redeemer he would be
appalled by our by by by what he seen
he'll be appalled by
Christianity okay and so this is what we
will discuss next class what I'll show
you next class is the true found of
Christianity the person who developed
this religion is not Jesus but
Paul okay Paul
all right so Christianity the religion
about Jesus is very different from Jesus
and what he really
taught
okay all
right was this clear to you guys any
questions
do you have any questions
EO okay so next class we will look at
Paul okay